the liberal system
is designed to advance this radicalism
it's not just one company it's not just
one guy it's the whole
system as a former executive for
transheiser Bush
explained just a couple of days ago
so how does this actually work these
guys are telling the truth here's how it
works it's pretty simple you just have
to follow the money if you take a look
at BlackRock State Street Vanguard they
manage 20 trillion dollars worth of
capital but it's not their own money
this is the money that everyday citizens
firefighters police officers doctors who
generally have their money either we
have 401ks or in a lot of cases large
Pension funds large Pension funds like
the state of California which manages
the largest pension fund in the U.S and
the state of New York and then European
European Pension funds as well and a lot
of the politicians in those States in
California for example they recently
have mandated those large Pension funds
that they divest from things like fossil
fuels and oil and gas and then when when
Bill de Blasio mayor of New York was
there did the same thing but they also
sell BlackRock State Street if they're
going to manage their money they have to
commit to things like ESG diversity
Equity inclusion and adopt firm-wide
commitments that they therefore then
Force onto all the major companies in
Corporate America
so obviously this guy Anson Fredericks
knows what he's talking about and Anson
is also one of the founders of strive
Asset Management which is Vivek
ramaswami's asset management company to
fight against woke investment what he's
describing this ESG movement is this
idea that the asset managers were able
to use your money to throw your weight
around for the for their ideological
celebrated causes and then Force the
corporations to get in line
very true and as this issue becomes more
prominent which it will over the next
year that's going to be very good for
vivek's presidential campaign
because everyone's looking for a lane
Trump is Trump he's running the Trump
Lane
populism
old right
old conservative kind of Lane
correcting a lot of the
ideological preferences on the right of
the last 20 30 years Rhonda Santos is
running in that same Lane he's just
running on an efficiency competency
platform
so he's saying I'm going to do all the
Trump stuff but I'm going to be better
at it I'm going to get it done in a way
that Trump was not able to get it done
and I'm going to win in a way that
Trump's not going to be able to win okay
that's that's where they're running
you've got Nikki Haley Tim Scott very
likely uh Mike Pence running in the same
Lane the sort of moderate acceptable
Centrist appeal to Suburban Housewives
kind of Lane
and then you've got the Vegas running in
this out of left field ESG Lane he's
running on the woke Incorporated stop
the woke takeover of corporate America
Lane that's that's an issue that is kind
of unique to him uh this is good this is
good news for his presidential campaign
right now go to grillblazer.com are you
tired of waiting ages for your grill to
heat up well now you can say goodbye to
those tedious moments of impatiently
watching the charcoal burn and say hello
to instant barbecue Perfection thanks to
our new friends over at Grill Blazer
Grill Blazers Grill guns are designed to
do everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything you can think of
that you would need a high power fire
source to solve that problem
[Music]
anything Grill Blazers offers two types
of Grill guns the grill gun basic is a
high power propane torch designed to
Light charcoal and wood grills and
smokers burns up to 3 600 Degrees 30
inch flame for anything you need a big
bed torch to do and the SUV gun has a
shorter Barrel perfect for professional
Culinary Kitchen uses from gently
carbonizing brulee or other sugars and
fruits to rapidly searing steaks outside
on the grill use the grill gun may
result in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors and increase demands for
barbecue parties get your grill gun from
Grill Blazers today let the grilling
Adventures begin realblazer.com Knowles
promo code nulls for 15 off your order
realblazer.com Knowles promo code nulls
for 15 off Canada
there's a new Public Health campaign
Canada's Public Health campaign
will be to print warnings on cigarettes
now we've had warnings on cigarettes for
many decades at this point and if you
ever travel to Europe you'll know that
the warnings get even more intense here
it just says surgeon general's warning
cigarettes are bad for you they can
cause cancer or they can cause birth
defects okay when you go to Europe it's
just these big letters of smoking kills
quit smoking now it's it's all sorts of
diseased organs it's jokes about
erectile dysfunction it's really
intensive in your face Canada is now
going further
as Canada seems to go further on
everything
the nicest people in the world seem to
go extremely to the extremes of
offensiveness and absurdity
more than anyone else on Earth and yet
they're so nice about it they're like
well you know wait hey don't you know
we're gonna go kill all the elderly and
the homeless people yes don't you know
uh so Canada has decided they're going
to print the warnings not just on the
cigarette cartons not just on cigarette
packs on the cigarettes themselves which
is really genius right you've already
you got the tobacco and you got all the
added chemicals that the cigarette
companies put in and now Canada is going
to add ink to that as well that's
probably healthy for you right and
Canada has announced that they're going
to put them on all the cigarettes
first country in the world to do so
they're hoping other countries follow
suit my question is
Canada going to do the same thing for
doobies
is Canada going to require warning
labels on big fat blunts is that the
next step no
no Canada is not going to do that
even though marijuana
is in many ways much worse for you than
cigarettes
will leave your lungs filled with more
tar than cigarettes will
that doesn't matter Canada has legal
marijuana not just for medical purposes
but for recreation too the Liberals in
Canada are all fine with you filling
your lungs with very toxic mind-altering
smoke
when it's the smoke that they like just
not the smoke that we like tobacco
broadly is preferred by conservatives we
like
cigars we like dip
we like
even cigarettes people who smoke
cigarettes tend to be of the working
class and so
while it's true that many of them might
vote Democrat the working classes
broadly tend to be
temperamentally
conservative ins constitutionally
conservative
they're not the radical activists out
there they're the kind of normal people
who like their norms and customs
that's who likes tobacco broadly
speaking the conservative people who
likes doobies I know that they're right
Wingers who like to smoke the devil's
lettuce puff on a few Jazz cigarettes
every now and again spark up the
Peruvian parsley but broadly speaking
the people who like
marijuana are the libs it's a lib thing
okay and so in Canada
you got two substances that you could
smoke one of which actually is worse for
you and it's marijuana
the marijuana no warning label it's fine
go do it it's great peace and love man
it's wonder drug it cures everything
tobacco which sharpens your mind makes
you quicker if it does anything at all
uh in addition to all the health
concerns the way it affects your mind is
it just makes you smarter and faster
that's the one that needs the warning
label
this is just a matter of imposing
political preference and culture on
people and ideology we're gonna we're
going to punish the conservative thing
we're going to support the liberal thing
this is why during covid the libs locked
down the churches they kept the pot
dispensaries open
this is why
the reason why is that they're going to
punish the conservative thing they're
going to reward and encourage the
liberal thing the libs view politics
as little more than a distinction
between friends and enemies
boy what a great clip that was make sure
you subscribe ring that Bell to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time